[Music]
latest measurements show lake mead's
water level is sitting at about 1048
feet that's right and while the lake is
at its lowest it will still be very busy
of course for the holiday weekend joe
muller shows us what boaters can expect
now that only one ramp is in use at
hemingway harbor this is the first
memorial day weekend there was only one
boat ramp in use some boaters decided to
come out early to avoid the long lines
in coming days it's like having the one
roller coaster
everybody waits in line for it getting
the boat in the water
is usually the start of a fun weekend
this is less crowded this is the only
wrap that's open boater stand coaches
decided it was best to get here thursday
come on saturday or friday you're going
to be waiting for two three four maybe
five hours low water levels have forced
the closure of all other ramps on lake
mead kelsey larson from the national
park service says crews continue to work
to move dirt to extend the last ramp we
do anticipate that the access to
hemingway harbor will remain stable
voters do get concerned about the last
ramp it's scary
we ran out of cement tom talbot says he
knew it would be busy too we came out
here and beat the crowds and
put it in the dock here boaters are
encouraged to launch as early as
possible
coaches plans to leave the boat docked
for days to avoid the lines again after
the holiday we take it out we'll take it
out on tuesday so we're on wednesday
while it will be busy here on lake mead
officials want to remind voters that
there are still three ramps in use at
lake mojave reporting at lake mead joe
mohler live local now